في عام 2018 رفضت وزاره التربيه في لبنان
منحه جامعه المصطفى الايرانيه ترخيصا
للعمل لكن الجامعه اللبنانيه عام 2022
اعلنت على موقعها الالكترونيه عن بروتوكول
تعاون بين الجميعتين رغم ادراج الجامعه
التي يمومها النظام الايراني على لائحه
العقوبات في اكثر من بلد
حاولنا الحصول على مقابله من رئيس الجامعه
اللبنانيه دون جدوى لفهم نوعيه الاتفاق
واهميته لصرح تاريخي ووطني جامع كالجامعه
اللبنانيه
العقبه مشان تقدر تستورد
بنيجي نحن من خلال الجامعه الوطنيه
اليوم اكيد الجامعه اللبنانيه بالاداره
الموجوده فيها حاليا
اقدمت على هذه الخطوه يتحمل رئيس الجامعه
اي مخاطر تتعرض لاله جامعه
المصطفى
لتورطه بالارهاب لديها اكثر من 50 فرعا
حول العالم من بينها فرع في ضاحيه بيروت
الجنوبيه
وكانت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه اتهمتها
بتجنيد عناصر لجمع معلومات استخباراتيه
وتنفيذ عمليات ارهابيه قد طلب الذين
جندتهم في افغانستان وباكستان وارسلتهم
الى سوريا تحمل
بثقافتها
وبتعاليمها
مشروع ولايه الفقيه
مشروع الايراني في المنطقه
وتاخذ الجانب
التربوي وديني
تحت حجه
البحرينيه وكل المعارضات العربيه
التي لديها ما يكفي من ازمات الى امتداد
ثقافيه صح حزب الله لنشره رغم التابعه
اغنيه يتيم العربيه بيروت